For the uninitiated, “This ain’t my first
rodeo” is roughly equivalent to telling
a person that you’re more than prepared
for a given situation or that it offers little
challenge to you.
It’s more often than not used derisively,
usually in situations where a more experienced
person is being given unwanted or unwarranted
advice by someone else.
The phrase is similar in inclination to the
British idiom, “I didn’t come down with
the last shower” (shower in this context
referring to rain), or the expression, “I
wasn’t born yesterday”.
As to the origin of the expression, it would
seem it isn’t nearly as old as you might
think.
The earliest known documented utterance of
it was in the 1981 film, Mommie Dearest, a
film adaptation of a book of the same name
chronicling the life of famed actress and
dancer Joan Crawford.
The book was a somewhat controversial tell-all
memoir written by Crawford’s deceased fourth
husband’s daughter, Christina Crawford,
where she portrays Joan Crawford as something
of an especially wicked step-mother.
A version of the phrase is uttered by the
actress playing Crawford in a particularly
well acted scene in which she is informed
by the Pepsi board of directors that she is
going to be forcibly removed from the board.
In response, Crawford verbally threatens everyone
present by stating she will publicly slam
the company and its product in an attempt
to bring it down if they remove her from the
board.
When a board member tries to reason with Crawford,
she angrily yells: “Don’t fuck with me
fellas!
This ain’t my first time at the rodeo.”
While it is certainly true that the real-life
Crawford was on the board of directors for
Pepsi after the untimely death of her husband,
the then president of the company, Alfred
Steele, and it also true that the board threatened
to remove her, there is little evidence that
Crawford ever uttered the line in real life.
However, it hasn’t stopped the quote from
being attributed to Crawford time and time
again.
In reality, as far as documented evidence
goes, the quote should either be credited
to Faye Dunaway, who played Crawford, or one
of the film’s writers, though which of them
came up with the line and how has seemingly
never been asked directly.
Of course, it’s now 34 years later, so it
would be a wonder if they remembered the details
accurately, or at all, concerning how that
seemingly insignificant line was thought up
or who they borrowed it from, if that’s
the case.
In any event, nine years after the release
of Mommie Dearest, the country singer Vern
Gosdin released a song simply titled “This
Ain’t My First Rodeo”.
The song was reasonably successful and is
often credited as the source of the expression,
but in reality simply went a long way towards
popularising it.
According to Vern, he first heard the phrase
after complimenting a couple of carpenters
working in his home on their work, at which
point one of them dryly responded “this
ain’t our first rodeo”.
The phrase intrigued Vern so much that he
jotted it down and later turned it into the
song.
Other’s credited with bringing the phrase
to popular attention include NASCAR driver,
Darrell Waltrip, who is recorded as having
said it in 1983 during a post-race interview,
and a Southern University coach named Gerald
Kimble who used it in 1989.